[Music]
so the demo was like 50 minutes that we
just saw the CD Projekt to set it to
deploy yet I said boy what you guys
think I was pretty I liked a lot dude I
was pretty damn impressed I don't know
about you guys but I was not expecting
it to be so good yeah it kind of
surprises me that they're not showing in
anis stuffing some good video asset
because it just looks so good
they had like mythical expectations that
have had to be yeah and I'll sound rude
you were saying especially you laugh
we're like it's visually you left that
game is done yeah because I
I feel like when you think of cyberpunk
you think of sort of the iconography of
like Blade Runner is sort of eternal
night and neon lights but for this one
is very colorful and that really
surprised me because the world looks
very vibrant and you know you see like
different cultures and we got a sense
that you know this world this actually
the world of the city itself which isn't
that cold night city is very big and you
know there's we've only just sort of
scratched the surface of what's there
yes oh they they said it was between San
Francisco and Los Angeles but like
obviously Kong yeah and I was really
surprised in the trailer just to see
that they had blue skies because always
seen is that teaser trailer of the
psionic cyborg with the planes standing
in the dirt yeah what they call mantas
aren't ready the developer on our stage
say like we can do night we can do
cyberpunk night like that's that that's
easier to do what we really want to nail
is cyberpunk in the day yeah which
sounds really like little but that is
pretty big right if you're gonna make a
living breathing world there's got to be
day and it still has to have that
atmospheric dark tone so that right
that's also like when it factors into
like you were saying was we saw it was
very much like you said it felt like
Hong Kong I know you go down and like
each time you come into be one of these
mega buildings they called them they're
essentially it's communities within
skyscrapers it's like they're like
apartment complex with one he started in
again first person when you're coming
down the elevator you just all of a
sudden see all these shops and all these
people and bustling freeways yeah and
like some dude is like preaching about
how corporations are the cancer of the
earth and then it's spreading to the
people but it was funny because watching
it you could have sworn that it was like
a pre-scripted demo but then of course
you look behind you and the one of the
CD Projekt guys was playing it on a
controller I don't know it was almost
like an exhausting demo to watch in a
good way there's every time I like I
think all right they can't show anything
more they're like but then you can do
this but then you can also do this or
you could have done this and it's like
wow like there's so many it seems like
there's so many different possibilities
based on that slice we saw essentially
the branching dialogue which sounds kind
of like a feature box to check off but
here like either that you were saying
even you can get hacked and then also
that plays into like every decision you
make throughout a mission it's like The
Witcher 3 you could decide this person
gets killed and then forget about it
until like 30 hours later and then see
their grave or something like to use a
Witcher 3 reference but based on the
demo we saw I'm sure they wanted to
script it for pacing for an e3 demo to
impress us I'm really curious to see how
those missions start like interweaving
and everything well one thing that was
interesting with that particular scene
when viga attacked was that they knew
they had pretty much a lie detector so
like you had dialogue options you could
pick from like they're like do you have
anyone with you and you had another
character who was hiding it away from it
and you say no and they're like he's
lying and then she like calls a drone
and the drones start seeking him out so
I think that's super easy that drone
later the drone comes out and when you
exit the other thing I was like oh [ __ ]
that was the one they sent out but yeah
that actually made the dialogue choice
meaningful I mean it's not just the
style choice you're picking like you're
actually thinking oh [ __ ] he's he
implanted the thing he knows literally
I'm lying
and people are like a lot of people are
mad than its first person what you have
to friggin see it okay I understand
loving the third person combat and world
exploration of The Witcher and lamenting
that loss but you can go play The
Witcher 3 nothing's stopping you
I think CV product has earned the clout
to do what they want in terms of
perspective and after seeing this I
wouldn't have it any other way
especially with them the gun and melee
calm I got on the melee combat as well
as as the density of the city so much
detail you want to see the grime on the
street
I think first person works really well
you can see like the coarseness of your
augmentations and they did a lot of
clever things in terms of keeping
information in your vision exactly they
wanted to keep that first-person
perspective as much as possible then
where the third-person cutscenes so you
can see your character who is completely
customizable and you can do third-person
when you're driving play a person coming
out of a car yeah the first time you
were saying I don't know what they gonna
do next when they get into the car like
Jesus I forgot that this was gonna be an
open-world drive any vehicle kind of
thing yeah and like even like the inside
like I was telling Jake I usually prefer
to drive do you like racing games from
the outside perspective but like the
dashboard with like that I kept
expecting everything lip on the window
yeah yeah my god the way that that came
up too tight the steering wheel itself
looked like it was just cobbled together
from scrap it was awesome but then I
don't know like just the banter I felt
like sometimes fell back too much on
cyberpunk
the John wrote ropes but I guess they
kind of have to do that for a demo yeah
it definitely wavered I'd say like some
of it I thought was pretty good and then
some was like alright this is pretty
trophy yeah one thing I found look that
was a bit overwhelming was because was
that it sort of pulls of upon the sort
of original pen and paper like
terminology and 2020 yes and it was a
little real whelming because i'm i had
to sort of remember what like core pose
are
you know hypose and a bunch of other
like terms but you know you get into it
really quickly after you know maybe the
first 10 15 minutes like you know during
the demo it was really it was just
really interesting seeing those like you
know sort of come to life in the world's
deftly coming back into vogue so even if
you aren't familiar with a pinup a but
you will get a lot of these so there's
signs of signifiers like yeah
cybernetic implants you could play
today's X you wanted me a lot of days X
in a lot of different ways but like the
game that Deus Ex the newer ones have
wanted to be those are great games
especially I like met a human revolution
a lot but yeah I feel like this is that
but it's like if ASX had in like a
hundred times the ambition like on
steroids yeah exactly that's that's
better way to put it and so like Deus Ex
combat was also kind of floaty and
yellow but the combat here I was saying
okay this feels like what they wanted to
do with Deus Ex what I have is Montreal
wanted to do with Deus Ex but then I
started thinking this reminds me a lot
of Bioshock in the way obviously hacking
is a huge part like literal hacking in
cyberpunk but there's something awesome
with hacking I want to get to another
second but um I mean you can decide to
you can go like you can be a pacifist
like the whole point it's a they they
want it to stress on our state this
morning it is first and foremost an RPG
and then an open-world shooter it is not
the other way around the CD Projekt The
Witcher 3 was one of the best RPGs we've
ever seen oh yes they are going all-in
on the RPG aspects but the combat itself
you can go stealthily you can go out
like gunplay the shooting it was hard to
tell because we can get our hands on it
but it looked a little stiff I think you
said yeah at least from from what I saw
like I like you said it's super hard to
tell but just you can tell it was played
with a controller and it didn't look
super smooth obviously if you're playing
on PC that's something you don't even
have to worry about and also like this
game is years out yeah and always remind
me on it because it was so action-packed
that he was chaining skills like jumping
- yeah activating bullet time mid-air
dodging and then shotgunning a guy in
the back yeah which is a surprise mate
but then you have to keep remembering
that this is an RPG that really
emphasizes it at the beginning when they
were creating their character they were
choosing their backstory sort of their
childhood heroes there was
stats that you could put points into
like strength oh cool
yeah very important that's a good
carrier from the medon paper and you
know there are sort of damaged numbers
and all that kind of stuff so it feels a
little bit ball and then every character
has a level as it leather right yeah and
that was a little bit odd at first
because like again when you first see
I'm like oh it looks I'm thinking in my
head this needs to look like a
first-person shooter but then as you go
through you're like wow this is
definitely an RPG yeah the way you can
approach it I absolutely loved
I don't know so me and Jake want to do a
different demo than you guys I mean it
was the same slice of the game but did
you see what they did with the stealth
takedown and hacking does that bring it
out that was really interesting because
basically you sort of a jack in yes yeah
like choked him out yeah and then yeah
an objective basically then you sort of
steal their information yeah you can
well the enemies of network together the
thing they did afterwards was a you know
they had to be who was the main
character you know approach like two
cars and she was above and we saw her
basically like sort of hack into the one
of the guards like weapons then she did
a self takedown on to the other guard
then the other guard who was still up
couldn't fire his weapon because it was
disabled yeah that startled he was like
yeah and then she just slowly walks up
and just like yes yes man these are
blazed yeah yeah as well as doing a wall
run and like slamming the blades into
the wall and getting an advantage point
yeah that was super cool but like it all
started because he decided to still take
down this one guy and I think the way
they phrase that he left the back door
in his in the position it brought up
this like holographic map of the hideout
itself and then it like zoom that the
animation of it was unreal I was like
yeah it's all the static and then it
kind of zooms in like almost like gta5
into the map it's floating and then it
comes back out and then you're ready
really like digital interface did you
guys see the inspection system - yes
yeah it was when you examine one of the
items and it's or like in sort of that
dirty digital right you can examine it
in 3d then you can find like sort of
hidden details of yeah yeah like weak
points and stuff like that well how many
you like hacking points you need to
break
that door one thing that I mentioned to
that I thought was cool is that the only
reason he was able to sort of survey the
environment like they get trapped in
that room for a second was because she
got that I installed before they allowed
her to like look around like alright
what is a good way to exit and then she
sees a panel on the wall she could hack
the door but her skull isn't high enough
but she had I think what did they call
it like mechanic skill or something
interest able to like pry open in here
engineering like pry open the control
panel and like move some wires around
and open the door and I'm gonna have to
say that's the same when they took Abby
to get her cybernetic implant I was so
good was so good and so like so what
happens is it's all first person and
then you see the machinery come down and
like take her eye out and like you see
the new eye that perspective than you I
come in and you get all the machinery
sort of like prying into you the doctors
there who like replace your
augmentations they're called doc rippers
yeah as opposed to like scrolling
through mean there's like a menu and
like an in-game menu that you scroll
through yeah like in the world yeah but
like those things don't just appear on
your character like you actually see
these animations of like you were saying
like pulling out the eye and stuff it's
really cool then like him putting me and
he's like I'm gonna put some anesthetic
before I start cutting and he's got this
like anesthetic gun that punches for
holes in her arm and then you look at
must've hurt and then like you get one
of them is a subdermal weapon in grip
which essentially I think the stats are
raised damage and it also pretty much
move your handling it's really cool how
like I and based on the menus I saw I
think you could change your appearance
appearance on the fly because they said
like you have so a your jacket is a
piece of gear like you're not getting a
Witcher armor you're getting it like the
leather samurai jacket had stats in
there like cool like you mentioned it
gave you better street cred yeah which
is like a currency I think you're
essentially using it to get new quests
and whatnot right you're like making
connections with different people
throughout nights and my assumption is
that when you interact with the
different corporations or gangs they
might react to it in different ways
based upon like how you look and
your credit industry is but I don't know
like Alessandra like I mean we're all
the CD Projekt fans but like this game
has pretty much taken on mythical
proportions since it was announced even
before the witcher 3 2013 5 years ago we
finally have seen it I don't know when
they're planning on showing this demo to
the public I hope soon I don't know what
they're waiting for
did it live up to your expectations or
what are you coming out of that demo
what are you thinking now
this is probably one of the most
impressive III demos I've seen in years
yeah it was one it was it was a little
bit overwhelming but at the same time is
very comprehensive because we got to see
a little bit of everything and what I
did see was something that you know
could be a really special title like in
the eye teacher
we only saw an hour of it right now and
I'm pretty excited hopefully the public
gets to see that down as well yeah
[Music]